hello and welcome to the first of a
two-part series of development diaries
for marksmen DLC first up we're going to
take a look at the content and features
that we've been working on for the last
couple of months
marksmen DLC is another opportunity for
us to take a look at the infantry
mechanics at the core of ARMA 3
it consists of a premium content package
as well as a free platform updates that
includes several really cool features
for weapon handling the real backbone of
the DLC is the seven new weapons
businesses very nice dark English column
bottom tanasha medve big hood in coloma
tea there are also two new scopes that
can be attached to old and new weapons
alike and there is ghillie suits for
snipers we started by asking the design
is what are you interested in what what
opportunities do you think around their
first to do something new we took each
weapon and tried to think about the
character of it what differences do they
have between each other what advantages
do they offer what new potential
gameplay can they bring to arma 3 how
many future doctor up to the album at
the mark seminar so stabilities brawny
bottom Novus wookie takipci develop
Shing mia intelligence asset ecard knock
a partner pot pourri ah good icky this
is the thing that everyone has been
waiting for by pots we have an active
component where you can really deploy by
pots on any type of stable servers for
new weapons old weapons community
weapons any type of weapon and then
there's the passive component which is
weapon resting that gives a stability
bonus whenever your arms or weapon are
near a stable surface bismuth this brine
bhutto see my commode lechita Nietzsche
Meatwad putita and about the consumers
at the buoy de dueño school dr. van de
lepcha put its dr. Emily bestia the way
you move on the battlefield becomes more
important and engagements hopefully
would last longer and be more satisfying
adding Bibles to the game took this long
because it was actually a very
complicated task we wanted the solution
that would work not just with our
weapons and with certain specific parts
of the terrain but everywhere and with
every weapon including community weapons
so we needed a real-time method of
scanning the terrain and determining
where you can actually deploy your
Bibles we have our own maps and it works
here but you also throw in a community
map it'll work just as well we also
looked at recoil over
all so we have a more accurate and
realistic but also better feeling type
of recoil for all the weapons firing a
weapon in Arma 3 is one of the most
basic things you can do we saw an
opportunity to to try and make the the
mechanic a bit more intuitive so we have
different calibers of weapon they react
in slightly different ways you have a
different kind of kickback we want to
make the choice of which weapon to use
in which situation a bit more meaningful
we sort of wrapped a bunch of small
features together and called it
something like environmental audio if
I'm firing a weapon on one side of a
hill and the rest of my team of my
enemies are on the other the sound of
the weapon is a slightly different
attenuated karachi buddha most elaborate
CT tectonic priority Makka pakka
asthenia touch with a message abbate in
yo intergen see there are Buddha Raghav
odna an object recording meet I versus
no [ __ ] beats agree terms of gameplay it
helps you sort of orient yourself a
little bit better on the battlefield you
know where these shots are coming from
or you have a sense of it but really
it's about the the richness of the
experience of being in a firefighter
she worried mark smelly poo Jared hood
neck near disturbs me in formatted
expert to the Christmas simultaneously
the valley planning firm a diverse
message I internet to upper unix dradis
kuzey good at this could lead actor is
brandon Moore published chilly one very
specific thing that we did was take the
whole team to the firing range in the
Czech Republic so we were all given the
opportunity to take a bunch of different
weapons of different calibers and ranges
and fire a couple of rounds the
community have been wanting us to handle
bipods for the longest time so it's
really satisfying to be able to offer a
robust engine based solution to this
specialist mesylate Nyako good lord of
navajo meza team habitable zone ADIZ
reality object on stylish as our metal
crashing i'm looking forward to the
audio improvements it's really complex
it's taken a lot of effort and there's
still a long way to go but i think
making improvements to this aspect of
the game can benefit the entire
experience of farmer three for me
personally what is really important is
that the marksmen DLC and the platform
update just bring the whole experience
much closer to how I myself experienced
it when firing weapons at the shooting
range from mujib Tallahassee Community a
city scotia tetralogy ho the tyranny
government displaced this post to novi
let me see brannie a feature there's a
lot to look forward to if the new rifles
are looking rather splendid and the new
features are really beginning to click
so that's just about wraps up this dev
diary thanks for watching next time
we'll take a look at the gameplay and
official scenarios offered by marksmen
DLC bye for now